[Music]
We don't have any place to go we as poor
and moderate-income people cannot afford
condominiums but we need someplace to
live we don't want to go to the suburbs
we want to stay in the city where
transportation [Applause] [Music]
Couldn't we go into the future? couldn't we talk
about people? when are we gonna stop talking about
it and really get something going I mean it's all
good we're saying here today we've got to do it
it's got to happen but what positive steps are
we gonna take. In the Bicentennial year American
minority needs for the third century were brought
into focus by the Chicago Urban League the best
minds listened and tried to respond to questions
that have become all too familiar by their sheer
persistence the idea was not a celebration not
self-congratulation but how can we improve things
in the future examine our problems and bring them
out into the light what are we to be doing to
be sure the process was a sort of town meeting
with experts from across the country to answer
questions from the floor you may have enough
housing for everybody but if somebody that's
us can't get that housing because they won't let
us in then that doesn't help us so that's where
race comes in we must have a basic change and the
economic policies of this nation there must be a
greater sharing of the work that is available
we have the numbers we are the largest ethnic
minority in America today but we must be made to
understand the power of the vote many questions
many statements many different individual
perspectives but all of them be coming in the kind
of inevitable focus the same question the same
statement and let's go forward which way [Music]
in this bicentennial year we whose measure
of freedom was purchased by so many at so
high a cost must dedicate and rededicate
ourselves unfailingly to freedom let us
select the several areas of greatest concern
and consider what goals are appropriate and
what means our best employ to achieve them
we're very proud of what happened at the
symposium a spontaneity of the audience the
openness and sharing concerns it's rare that
ordinary people and people of influence can meet
as equally exploring options for change together
usually there's no dialogue and to the need for
change becomes so critical that some kind of
confrontation occurs as a catalyst organization
the League is committed to fostering this kind
of dialogue and developing solutions to common
problems [Music] [Applause] [Music] [Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]